he's - totally fast totally cool totally  in trouble you can see more of - in  Disney Pixar's Incredibles 2 in theaters  June 15 hello honey things haven't  spirals out control the moment I left  everything's great parenting is their  heroic looks normal to me is freaky  [Music]  I'll watch the kids no problem  not the way you're supposed to do it why  did they change my injector he's in  excellent health  [Music]  is freaky Disney Pixar's Incredibles to  see the full trailer online now  [Music]  is that a new job doing hero work I  couldn't have done this if you hadn't  taken over so well Pixar see Incredibles  2 in theaters June 15 this film not yet  rated  you